♪ ♪
>> Greg: FAUCI WAS WARNED, BUT
THE EMAILS WAS GOING TO.
"THE WASHINGTON POST" OBTAINED
HUNDREDS OF PAGES OF DR. FAUCI'S
EMAILS FROM THE EARLY DAYS OF
THE PANDEMIC.
ASIDE FROM THE USUAL REQUEST
FOR -- THEY REQUIRED
CORRESPONDENCE.
THERE REALLY WEREN'T NUDES, WAS
WAITING TO SEE IF THE AUDIENCE
WAS LISTENING.
THE VIRUS HAD SOME UNUSUAL
FEATURES AND LOOKED ENGINEERED.
ERIC A NELSON WROTE TO FAUCI
SAYING CHINA HAD BEEN LYING AT
THEIR DEATH TOLL ADDING "THE
DATA POSTED BY CHINA IS NOT ON
THE GARBAGE, IT HAS MISLED THE
WORLD INTO A FULL SET OF
SECURITY.
THE DEATH RATE AND AGE VERSUS
DEATH -- I TRULY BELIEVE THE
OUTBREAK IS EITHER ALREADY
HAPPENED OR IS ABOUT TO HAPPEN.
NOW THAT IS JUST PART OF THE
EMAIL.
IT WENT ON FOR SEVERAL PAGES,
WHICH APPARENTLY FAUCI DIDN'T
HAVE TIME FOR BECAUSE HE
FORWARDED THE EMAIL TO A MEMBER
OF NIH WRITING, TOO LONG FOR ME
TO READ.
TOO LONG FOR ME TO READ, I WOULD
BE A GREAT NAME FOR HIS BOOK.
IF WHOOPS I [BLEEP] UP WASN'T
ALREADY TAKEN BY ANDREW CUOMO.
I USUALLY STOP READING EMAILS
AROUND 500,000.
EVERY TIME.
>> I CAN'T HELP IT.
HER LITTLE POINTY ARMS, THEY
CAN'T DO [BLEEP] TO ME.
I WOULDN'T BE WORRIED ABOUT HIM
GETTING UP.
I'M LITERALLY IN A WHEELCHAIR
AND HE'S THE ONLY ONE HERE WITH
A BETTER CHAIR.
I DON'T KNOW HOW THIS DECISION
WAS MADE.
>> YOU WOULDN'T ENJOY IT.
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT, BUT THE
VISIT DON MIKE PHYSICIST WAS
RIGHT THERE THEY HAVE
APPROXIMATELY 4600 DEAD FROM
CORONAVIRUS.
IN ANOTHER DIFFERENT EMAIL, A
RESEARCHER THANKS FAUCI FOR
DISMISSING THE WUHAN LAB LEAK
EARLY ON CALLING FAUCI BRAVE FOR
DISPELLING MYTHS ABOUT THE VIRUS
ORIGINS.
LIKE THE COST OF FRIENDS, THAT
DIDN'T AGE WELL.
SUCH A GREAT LINE.
I THINK I'M GOING TO STOP RIGHT
THERE.
DO YOU THINK -- DO YOU THINK
THEY SHOULD BUILD A STATUE OF
FAUCI?
>> 1000%.
GREAT TITLE, TOO LONG FOR ME,
THAT'S HILARIOUS.
TOO LONG TO READ THAT CHINA
EMAIL.
BUT LET'S REVIEW WHAT FAUCI DID
HAVE SOME TIME TO EMAIL.
HE HAD TIME TO RESPOND TO
FRIENDS WHO SAID HE HAD A
CULTLIKE FOLLOWING TO WHICH
FAUCI REPLIES, I CAN'T WAIT FOR
THIS TO END.
YEAH RIGHT, HE'S ENJOYING IT.
THEN HE EMAILS A FRIEND AND
SAID, THEY SAID I LOOK LIKE
BRAD PITT ON "SNL."
THAT MADE MY DAY.
AND MY FAVORITE ONE IS WHEN HE
SENDS OUT A HEADLINE THAT SAYS
"CRUSH CUOMO AND FEVER FAUCI,
THE SEXUALIZATION OF THESE MEN
IS REAL."
THAT IS WHAT HE WAS DOING DURING
A PANDEMIC.
>> Greg: I LOVED IT.
I DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT THE
DOUGHNUTS.
FAUCI DOUGHNUTS, THEY ARE
HOLIER-THAN-THOU.
>> THEY ARE.
>> Greg: THIS IS WHY I HAVE A
SHOW.
I COME UP WITH THINGS LIKE THAT.
IT IS IT NOT UNDENIABLE?
>> IT IS UNDENIABLE FOR ONLY YOU
TO COME UP WITH THAT.
YOU ARE 100% RIGHT.
I FIND THIS TRAGICALLY
DISGUSTING.
YOU HAD TIME TO THROW IT FIRST
PITCH IS, YOU HAD TIME TO DO
EVERY TOUR ON EVERY TV SHOW AND
BE PRAISED, BUT YOU DIDN'T HAVE
TIME TO READ AN EMAIL WHICH WAS
SPECIFIC TO YOUR JOB.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT SCIENCE
AND DOCTORS ARE SUPPOSED TO DO A
LOT OF HIS READING.
IT'S LIKE THEIR NUMBER ONE
THING.
YOU HAD ONE JOB.
YOU ARE IN CHARGE OF INFECTIOUS
DISEASES AND YOU HAD SOMETHING
SPARKED OFF AND YOU PASSED IT
OFF TO SAY IT'S TOO LONG TO
READ.
THERE WAS NO OTHER FOLLOW-UP
EMAIL.
SO WHAT DID YOU COME UP WITH?
WAS THERE ANYTHING INTO IT?
DO I NEED TO CHECK IT?
WHERE IS THAT?
HE LITERALLY DISMISSED IT
BECAUSE IT WASN'T IMPORTANT TO
HIM WHEN IT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
IMPORTANT TO HIM.
SO JUST LIKE WE LIKE TO GO
AND -- IF THE GLOVE FITS, IT
DOES IN THIS ONE.
THIS ISN'T AN O.J. SYSTEM.
BUT THERE NEEDS TO BE THE SAME
ATTITUDE TOWARDS FAUCI AND HOW
HE IGNORED THE RED FLAGS, SIGNS,
YELL, LOOK AT ME APPEARED THERE
IS A PROBLEM HERE.
AND HE JUST LET IT GO BECAUSE HE